When I was 17, I got pregnant.
And the light of my life is my father but he gave me 24 hours to leave town.
And I gave this baby up for adoption and said at that time that I will adopt a child...
...when I'm able to take care of a child.
Wow.
I just wasn't ready for that.
I'm sure.
So many times I would think, "Gosh, is this the time to tell him?"
But I'm 73 now and it just seems like such a big secret.
It's kind of funny, I think where you're concerned, I try not to be very emotional...
...and I worry that you'll never know just how deeply I love you...
...and how scary it is for me sometimes to imagine life without you.
That's something I can't make better for you.
And I don't doubt it'll be tough but you'll be okay.